hi friends how was you nights sleep was
it good
hopefully after today's episode it's
going to be better today we're going to
speak to dr. Greg Potter who is a PhD
graduate from the University of Leeds
and a specialist in sleep his work has
been featured absolutely everywhere from
writers to Time magazine Washington Post
USA Today Daily Telegraph BBC radio he's
he's pretty prolific and he's also the
content director at human OS dot me now
the guys at human OS haven't sponsored
this episode at all however it is a
fantastic service that you should check
out and later on in the episode Greg
explains what it's all about but if you
do want to go and have a look it's free
to sign up and with the code modern
wisdom you can actually get there
premium version for $1 for the first
month and there's no minimum term so
check it out now many people take a lot
of time researching the diet or their
exercise and making sure that they're
trying to live a healthy life but quite
a lot of us overlook just how important
sleep is in this equation and having
read Matthew Walker's book why we sleep
I was struck by just how little care I
was giving to my sleep habits the
implications on your health mood and
performance both in the short and long
term pretty drastic and I don't think
that there can be enough weight applied
to just how important sleep is now
hopefully today we're going to convert
you from a non-believer to sleep
Paragon who is armed with some new tools
to improve their sleep and a passion to
actually make it better
essentially what I'm saying is that if
you live a long and healthy life with
all of your faculty
still intact at the ripe old age of 95
you can be on your deathbed incredibly
mobile and full of Zen and look back at
this podcast and thing thanks Chris and
dr. Greg
[Music]
dr. Greg Potter welcome to modern wisdom
thanks very much it's great to be here
how are you today yeah I'm very well
Howie
fantastic thank you did you get a good
night's sleep not bad
been up for a while bye bye whose
standards did you have a not bad night's
sleep
I'm my own not particularly good
standards right
rigorous sleep standards right well I
don't set the bar too high but the last
few weeks have been a bit ropey at times
is it do as I say not as I do
yeah it's one of those so can you
explain to the listeners what your
speciality is what your what you focus
on in your research area sure so I have
just passed my PhD congratulations thank
you very much rich was at the University
of Leeds and I'm in Leeds right now and
during my PhD I focused on sleep diets
and metabolic health in UK adults so I
focused on studies of human beings and
in my PhD there were several different
parts it began with the validation of a
dietary recall method so if the
nutritionist is interested in how diet
affects health and risk of various
diseases then they need accurate ways of
capturing what somebody eats and to that
end you need to validate the tools that
you use and I was involved in the
violation of one of those tools which is
called my food 24 and it's the first
validated tool designed for you
specifically with adults in the UK it's
very comprehensive and that paper is
just being published and I then use that
data set to look at associations between
when people eats relative to when they
sleep and then that colic health I also
did some work looking at how sleep
duration is associated with risk markers
that are associated with diabetes in the
UK and also how people eat and then at
the end of my PhD thesis
did a randomized control trial of
long-term melatonin supplementation
among people who are at high risk for
type 2 diabetes so let's say for example
Chris that your dad has type 2 diabetes
that would increase your susceptibility
to that disease question was can you use
melatonin as a prophylactic agent
against you developing type 2 diabetes
so just wrapped all of that stuff up and
now I work for human OS as content
director and I've been working with
those guys for about the last 18 months
or so and more or less been working
full-time for the last four months under
the CEO also has a strong background in
sleep research so he share that in
common
but you're in good company then yeah I
would say so for sure that's fascinating
I mean is there's an awful lot an awful
lot to go through there but I know that
a lot of the people who are listening
will have heard me mention a number of
times Matthew Walker's book why we sleep
I think that probably up there with my
most ever listen to podcasts between him
and Joe Rogan and it's gonna be it's
gonna be really really interesting to be
able to dig into what I've heard and and
read about so much and and try and
actually elicit some of the answers that
I think it may be missing from my body
of knowledge and then give the listeners
a little bit more a little bit more of
an understanding of why sleep is
important and what it does to people and
then I'm super excited to talk about
human OS as well i earlier on today had
a pretty comprehensive browse of the of
the site so we'll be able to finish up
with that at the end so a lot to get
through today Ashley fantastic so to get
started do you know why we sleep no not
really that's great so it's a
long-standing question in sleep research
and there are many different ways that
you can try and address it what I'll say
is that there's no real consensus right
now and I think it's worth thinking
about why we sleep from evolutionary
perspective
and when you think about sleek and this
is something that Matt discusses at
length and with great clarity in his
book sleeps very strange and that while
you're asleep you can't eat you can't
gather food you can't have sex and
you're vulnerable and for all of those
reasons there should have been very
strong evolutionary pressure against the
development of sleep like behavior
incredibly vulnerable right yeah
absolutely but as far as we can tell
more or less all species studied have
sleep like behavior we spend a third of
our lives doing it so the question is
why is that the case and I think that in
reality it probably serves different
functions in different species what's
interesting is that different organisms
have very different sleep patterns both
the time you have a sleepin also how
long they sleep and there are various
things that seem somewhat predictive of
sleep so things like the complexity of
social networks nervous system
complexity type of diets the animals
consume but knowing one thing is
strongly is a strong determinant of
sleep in animals so anyway what happens
during sleep well it's a period of
adaptive inactivity and one of the
functions is probably its optimize the
timing and duration about to activity to
do things like reduce the risk of
predation and also to ensure food
acquisition another function is energy
conservation but actually if you look at
the amount of energy that you save by
sleeping versus just being awake and
relatively inactive it's very very small
so that's not a particularly persuasive
evolution hasn't given us this because
it lowers our requirement for food
doesn't seem to be the case
not knowing humans if for example you
look at all of the studies that have
been done on the effects of sleep
restriction on energy expenditure the
effects are negligible we're speaking
about the amount of energy that's
contain the slice of bread
you just have another have another bit
of bread - you'll be fine honestly stay
up all night off you face on bread and
then the next day you'd be fine well
bread
pleasing in it and that will probably
get oh no trigger everybody so anyway
there are also different things that we
passed through during sleep in each of
those serves related but distinct
functions so if for example you look at
non REM sleep
non REM meaning non-rapid eye movement
there are three stage that this type of
sleep each of which becomes
progressively deeper by which I just
mean that it's harder to wake someone
non REM sleep there are processes like
nervous system restoration energy
conservation and pruning away
connections in your brain that you use
during the day but weren't highly used
and therefore don't seem to be necessary
to hold on to you during the stage of
sleep there's also a kind of waste
disposal system that becomes active in
the brain and there's a study that's
published about five years ago is
showing that during sleep and mice the
plumbing in this system effectively
opens up and cerebrospinal fluid washes
toxic debris out of the spaces in the
system that's accumulated during the
daytime so that seems to be one of the
functions of maps you can cycle sleep
does that does that explain an increase
in clarity of thought the next morning
after you've had a good night's sleep to
one degree yeah would do it would do
absolutely and then another stage of
sleep that you enter after that deepest
stage of sleep is the stage with which
most people are most familiar rapid eye
movement sleep which is that stage in
which you dream it's cool rapid eye
movement because of the ways that your
eyes dart from side to side during the
stage it's quite strange in that even
though parts of your brain are as much
as thirty percent more metabolically
active at this time than they are during
wakefulness your muscles are completely
paralyzed so that you don't act out your
dreams yeah what this creates is an
environment in which you can take
information you've accumulated during
the day and then consolidated during
deep sleep and you can collide all these
different sources of information in your
brain to form new connections and
through those new associations you seem
to be able to generate create
of ideas and what's very interesting
actually is that if you look at human
specifically then we spend maybe twenty
to twenty-five cents of our sleep in REM
sleep which is more than any other
primate but we sleep less than any other
primate and some people speculate that
this disproportionately large amount of
REM sleep that we have as humans has
been fundamental to the development of
our intelligence and our complex social
structures so that's quite interesting
that is interesting I'd I'd seen the
study that you're talking about to do
with want a study that related to new
connections in the brain when you're
asleep and recently did a podcast with
the author of make it stick Peter C
Brown and during that he said that one
of the key determinants of your capacity
to learn is doing focused concentrated
work and then going away from it and
then coming back and I think that that
generating new connections and viewing
anecdote leads say you're viewing
something with a new perspective but it
seems that that's actually being
reflected physiologically within the
brain yeah and there are probably a
couple of things to touch on there so
one is learning during the day and the
importance of spacing because it's been
years and years more than a decade since
I looked at any of this research but in
psychology there are so called primacy
and recency effects which just means
that you tend to remember what you learn
at the start of a learning bout and the
end of it too and you don't remember the
stuff in the middle so much so what that
means is that let's say that you've got
six hours in which to learn you're
better off taking regular small breaks
and then by doing so you create more
opportunities for these primacy and
recency effects and then while you're
not doing learning you want to take your
mind entirely off the task so that's one
component to the puzzle but another
component to the puzzle is about during
learning or between learning periods
themselves okay
this is something that you want to
return to later but the way that that
happens is relatively well understood
there are specific aspects of the
process that are controversial and
there's not complete consensus on but
it's something that's probably worth
understanding because actually it is
information you can use to improve your
ability to learn
that's fascinating is the is the sleep
industry of researchers is it quite
dogmatic or there's some pretty sort of
standoffish camps
I don't know how militant the the sleep
world is well you're speaking about a
bunch of academics and I would put them
quite firmly in the passive category as
individuals okay
I've never seen a fire at a conference
okay that said that there is contention
over some things and I think that it's
often the case that somebody's view will
be ingrained early on and then it'll go
period of time without being challenged
yep and there's been the so called
replication crisis in science recently
and it's received an awful lot of
attention in the media I think
psychological research in particular has
come under fire for the inability to
reproduce the results of previously done
studies and what's nice now is that more
and more journals and assessor tating
that people make their data open access
after publishing so people can revisit
what other scientists did to me that
they did in fact do what they said they
did and to make sure that they haven't
dredged through their data and tried to
come up with a way of analyzing their
data to support their hypothesis rather
than going in there beforehand and
saying okay this is how I'm going to
look at my research question and
regardless of what the results are
I'm sticking to my guns but that's the
that's the scientific principle right
you shouldn't be trying to make the
research fitter
a previously held hypothesis that's not
the way that it's supposed to be but I
can imagine that a lot of people once
they've got their teeth once they're
certain about something conceptually
they want the research to then reflect
that yeah and an issue is that it's
difficult to publish negative findings
in scientific journals by negative
findings I don't mean that they're
disheartening or anything like that I
mean there's no effect of a on B yep and
it's less it's less glitzy right it's
not as much of a melatonin doesn't it
doesn't affect sleep quality isn't as
much of an exciting title that might
actually be but something else that a
doesn't affect me it's not as
attention-grabbing right yeah it's not
gonna get on the from age at the
Washington Post any time see I go in so
we understand we have a beginning of an
understanding of what we think sleep is
required for from an evolutionary
perspective do we know how much is
optimal is there an agreed-upon time
it's kind of this wives tale anecdote
that eight hours is how much we need a
night is that is that correct there are
guidelines but you can't take the
guidelines and assume that you're
correct that they are correct for you as
an individual the guidelines vary
according to how old somebody is so if
you look at young people they need more
sleep than adults and for adults
according to the National Sleep
Foundation on average we need 7 to 9
hours per night but there is relatively
substantial variability between people
in sleep need and one other thing that
I'll add is that the amount of sleep
that you need is a moving target so I
don't know what your experience is but
for me for example I generally find that
I sleep more in the winter than I do in
the summer and I think that's probably
somewhat relates to the photo period
also if I'm going through a period in
which I'm exercising too intensively
then I'll need more sleep if I have a
cold that I'll need more sleep if I'm
stressed about something and I have a
deadline on horizons then
it's just as if the alarm clock in my
brain just comes online little bit
earlier yeah for that reason invariably
I sleep less so even though we have
these generic targets I think that
actually fundamentally you give yourself
the opportunity to get the sleep that
you need by getting in bed on time you
focus on preparing for sleep as well as
possible by getting in the right frame
of mind and also supplying with your
body with what it needs ensuring that
your environments around use conducive
to good sleep and then you don't wake up
to an alarm and you see how long you
sleep and it sounds facile to explain
that way but I do think that that is how
it is with all that that seven to nine
hours is a good baseline for most people
and we understand more and more about
some of the things that do influence why
some people need more or less sleep but
some people I think historically have
thought that there are those lucky few
out there the Margaret Thatcher of the
world who need three hours of sleep and
they function just fine and that just
doesn't seem to be the case so of all of
the genetic variants that have been
identified so far the particular variant
that's associated sure to sleep
phenotype is on average a variant that
has adult sleep about 6.2 hours per
night which i think is probably far more
than most people would expect the shorts
of sleepers to sleep is that the
phenotype which is present in the same
percentage of people that get hit by
lightning is it the incredibly rare one
you hit that sounds right is it I think
it's one in a hundred and twenty
thousand or something like that it's
very good right so I think it's safe to
assume that you don't have that I think
it's like for the vast majority of
people that are listening so what that
means is you need to be aiming for
between seven and nine hours and just
how important is sleep to
short-term and long-term health that's a
very big question yeah okay so so where
would you like me to start with that we
can speak about metabolism or let's take
it from the top wherever it wherever you
think's best to set the scene and go
from there okay well I suppose there are
different ways of looking at obviously
you can't have an intervention in which
over a very long period of time you have
one group of people shorten their sleep
and you have another group sleep as much
as they'd like
so in order to get at the effects of
sleep on the population level people use
epidemiology to study populations and
typically those types of studies will
just have people answer questions about
sleep and then researchers will
associate how long people report
sleeping various health outcomes and
preferably they will also follow them up
over time so in those circumstances
prospective studies like that can be
used to see whether short sleep at
baseline predicts greater development of
chronic disease further down the line
for instance okay so that's that's one
way of looking at things from the bads
that there are all sorts of confounding
variables so itself it's self-reported
right it's hardly a scientific approach
yeah but it is a scientific approach but
it's not objective okay but that's the
point and in order to get a more
objective handle on the effects of
disrupted sleep on various outcomes you
need to look at sleep studies in which
people come in the environment into the
laboratory environment and they are
given a certain amounts of time in bed
and then you assess various outcomes of
interest so if we start with metabolism
for example then we've known for about
20 years now that as little as five
nights of shortening somebody sleep to
four hours per night results in
otherwise healthy young people
temporarily becoming pre pre-diabetic
well not only that
they also tend to eat differently so
that effect is seen when somebody's diet
is held constant but if you let people
choose what they then on average
restricting somebody sleep duration to a
period of say four to six hours per
night tends to increase the amounts of
energy they consume by about 385
calories a day okay which doesn't sound
like much but of course health is the
consequence of your behaviors over a
long period of time so you cumulative
effects of all of these small impacts
adds up something meaningful and 385
calories day over the course of the year
that's the amount of energy that's
stored in about 18 kilograms of fat
tissue you would gain 18 kilograms of
fat tissue because you have this live
post that in your brain which will
actively try to defend how much fat you
carry so it's relatively unwavering but
you are likely to gain weight let's put
it that way so sleeping sleeping less
means eating more and it's I'm gonna
presume that people when they are tied I
know for myself if I've had a really bad
night's sleep or if I haven't slept
enough I'll reach for less healthy foods
as well that's exactly right yeah so
it's not only the amount of food that
people are eating but it's also the
quality of food that seems to be
affected by sleep loss and in the last
maybe decade people have started to look
at the effects of sleep loss on patterns
of activity in the brain in response to
food stimuli so for example you can have
somebody come into the lab you can
completely deprive them of sleep over
the previous evening and then show you
them images of cupcakes and cookies and
you can compare their brain activity in
that situation to when they're allowed
as much sleep as they would like and
after the sleep deprivation areas of the
brain they're involved in motivation and
reward to acquire food lights up like
Christmas tree
and not only that but the prefrontal
cortex which is the most recent
of all dairy the brain you can think of
it as the brain CEO or the part of the
brain that lets you do the right thing
when it's more difficult thing to do is
less well connected to other regions of
the brain so it doesn't have the ability
to override those urges and some of the
more primitive parts of the brain and
the limbic system tend to be more active
- so you have this double whammy of
brain activity that makes it
increasingly hard to avoid succumbing to
the temptations of things that our
bodies are hard-wired to gravitate
towards like lots and lots of calories
that's interesting so I know a lot of my
friends that do sports and some of them
will be prepping for bodybuilding
competitions fitness shows across the
competitions that are coming up
specifically when they're in a deficit
if they're dieting hard trying to cut
before a show I know that they struggle
with their sleep so what you're saying
is that the poor night's sleep that
they've potentially got perhaps because
of being hungry or perhaps just because
of stress about the show or whatever it
might be is making the next day of
deficit eating even more difficult and
requiring even more willpower to not go
and get a cookie from the dicovered yeah
unfortunately that is a vicious cycle
that is a very very vicious cycle so
apologies to the guys that again ready
for shows that are listening but you
just need to go to bed a little bit
earlier I think so what about the effect
of sleep on mood so if you look at sleep
duration and neurodegenerative disease
and also various mood disorders bipolar
disorder major depression there seems to
be strong associations there so it it
appears to be the case that almost no
mood disorder in almost no mood disorder
people experience normal healthy sleep
there's always some sort of disruption
and what I'm most familiar with is the
effects of circadian system disruption
on mood and also how sick
rhythms are misaligned inserts and mood
disorders but can you briefly explain
what a circadian rhythm is for us please
sure
so organisms evolved in this 24-hour
light-dark cycle that we experience each
day not only that that's nested within
the context of these seasonal changes in
various environmental conditions and to
thrive in those environments they needed
to develop timing systems that help them
anticipate daily changes in the
environment change in temperature taint
change in light exposure because with
that came changes in food availability
and predation risk and so on and over
the course of millions of years almost
all not all organisms evolved these
internal timing systems and a circadian
rhythm is a rhythm that has a period of
about 24 hours but it's not precise in
24 hours these rhythms are self sustains
so they repeat of their own accord
day after day they're persistent and
their untrainable so because they're not
exact in 24 hours they need to be reset
each day and the strongest entraining
agent in the environment the resets our
biological rhythms as humans is the
light-dark cycle and that does so by way
of it's called the photon your endocrine
system but it's just the way that light
is perceived by specialized cells in the
eyes and these specialized cells then
relay information about light exposure
to the so called master clock in the
suprachiasmatic nucleus in the
hypothalamus and this master clock just
sits atop where the two optic nerves
that come from the eyes to the visual
cortices is placed and it samples
information about flight environment
over time it then knows what time of day
it is outside roughly and it uses
various ways of sending this time of day
signal elsewhere in the body
so perhaps the best-known of those is
via
the pineal gland and subsequently
melatonin synthesis so as light comes in
your eyes this signal was then
transferred back to the pineal gland via
the master clock and light exposure
offsets melatonin synthesis during
darkness that signal is no longer coming
in so the pineal gland synthesizes
melatonin and then melatonin relays this
signal of darkness throughout the body
because many of your body's tissues have
their own melatonin receptors and
through that mechanism they know that
it's dark outside and forming nighttime
activities but it's not only melatonin
that the system uses it also uses things
like changes in body temperature each
day another very important hormone in
the circadian system is cortisol and if
you look at the daily rhythm of cord so
then in anticipation of waking each day
you see this big spike in cortisol in
healthy people maybe an hour or so
before waking up and what that does is
mobilizes Thord energy reserves in
things like your muscles it increases
your blood pressure your heart rates and
it readies your body for the day ahead
so that's one other key agent and then
the master clock itself also sends out
or secretes its own substances that then
reach other areas of the brain and help
coordinate the timing of all these
different body systems so the circadian
system as a whole optimizes your body
for the needs of the present moment and
in this way for example you will be at
your strongest during the day time your
digestive system is best set digest food
during the active period and at night
time
your appetite will naturally wane you'll
have a drop in core temperature and
brain temperature and that improves your
ability to fall asleep you will see a
spike in growth hormone which will help
you preserve your lean body mass
overnight and overall the net effects of
this symphony if you like is to make
sure that if everything
is working properly then your whole body
is optimized for the needs of the
present moment okay so that's what a
circadian rhythm is I'm gonna guess that
that that requirement for light and dark
to regulate our sleep is why seasons
specifically in places like the UK where
we do have quite a big disparity between
summer day lengths and winter day
lengths I'm gonna guess that that's one
of the reasons that people may struggle
to wake up in the morning or may find
sleep different between seasons is that
right yeah it is and there's not
actually very strong evidence of
seasonal differences in people sleep
patterns in art in artificially lit
environments because everywhere you go
in the UK you can't escape a street lamp
yeah or light from buildings or whatever
but if you take people and you haven't
go camping during the winter you can go
camping during the summer then you will
you will see quite rapid changes in
people's sleep patterns the track
changes in the light-dark cycle and one
thing that you mentioned there which is
relevant to mood disorders the circle
back to that is how that changes over
time and how some people may find it
hard to wake up certain times of the
year or just feel worse so seasonal
affective disorder for instance is quite
commonplace and it's more commonplace
the further from the equator that you
move so a higher latitudes and what you
find is that around the time that we
transition and the clocks switch back
each autumn you tend to see a spike in
people who report experiencing
depression at those times and actually
the scalene system is a point at which
you can intervene in order to try to
help those people so do you think that
that's do you think that the reports of
depression are to do with the single
night of lack of sleep or that that is a
marker that the days are getting to a
length where that would occur yeah I
think it's pretty a bit of both because
that's crazy that a single a single
change in time would elicit
a response from you know a general
population yeah I think the strongest
evidence that the change in time
producing that kind of response is
daylight savings time so during the
spring time when we lose an hour of
sleep each year you tend to see a spike
in traffic accidents at that time of the
year for example there's also some
relatively weak evidence that you might
see an increase in cardiovascular
incidents at that time so an increase in
things like heart attacks off the back
of one night well it's it's one night
acutely but of course people have to
keep waking up early so let's say that
the first night you lose an hour of
sleep and then you start to adjust to
being a little bit earlier you never
fully adjust so maybe the second week
you're losing 45 hours of sleep the
third you're losing thirty minutes of
sleep and so on yeah I think that
there's a cumulative effect there over
time so I think that's that's probably
the best evidence of that type of acute
disruption to sleep having long-term
consequences for lots of people but also
that there is this change in photo
period that seems to independently
affect risk of people experiencing
certain things okay and I think
particularly up and up at the polls
people are very high risk for that yeah
definitely I mean there's period entire
months where the Sun doesn't set you
know if you were ever if you're ever
gonna be somewhere and stuff with
seasonal affective disorder it's gonna
be it's gonna be either of the polls so
go back to moods have we is there any
research which shows a link between
someone with sleep as sleep deprivation
and depression that's an interesting
question because actually historically
sleep deprivation has been used as an
antidepressant Rick okay yeah a single
night of sleep deprivation so quite
often it's the case that people with
depression will experience portly
and if you deprive somebody of sleep
over one night then they have this
really strong increase in the pressure
to sleep and then in subsequent nights
they sometimes find it easier to get
back on to some sort of consistent sleep
schedule but wiping the etch-a-sketch
board clean so to speak kind of yeah but
but also during that night of sleep loss
people's new does tend to improve
acutely and we don't really understand
fully why that so I haven't looked
closely at that research I know that
somebody who I've collaborated with the
University of sorry's published some
work on that and they looked at the
metabolome which is where you basically
take a biological sampling so let's say
you take somebody's blood and you look
at all of the metabolites that are in
that blood sample at that particular
time of day and you can take them a
various points during the day and look
at how the metabolites respond to
various interventions so for example
diet or sleep loss and if you look at
the effects of sleep loss and I think
that there's evidence that you see
changes in serotonin signaling serotonin
metabolites and serotonin is a
neuromodulator
neurotransmitter which is important to
things like mood and sexual function
motivation all sorts of things but I
think that the strongest evidence of
course that serotonin is critical to
that is the fact that what's the most
common antidepressant medication people
use in suits SSRIs yeah the uptake
inhibitors which basically prolong being
the amount of time that serotonin is in
the synapse between neurons and the
brain it reduces the clearance of the
serotonin from those so sleep
deprivation does have these short-term
antidepressant effects but those effects
aren't sustained over time and actually
as I alluded to before what you tend to
see is that over the long-term
of course where sleep is associated with
form read
the tricky thing as I as I briefly
touched on is just that often somebody
sleeps poorly but how do you causally
tie that to some specific outcome in an
observational study when people sleep
poorly
might be smoking more they might
experience more stress at home perhaps
they drink they have all these other
lifestyle behaviors that negatively
affect the health outcome in question
yeah it's very difficult to isolate
right yeah that's it
so I one thing that's interesting here
is there a way that sleep scientists
have been able to detect the arrow of
causality between sleep and issues or
issues and sleep is am i sleeping badly
because I'm depressed or am i depressed
because I'm sleeping badly for instance
yeah it's I think it's easier to address
the former question because you can
disrupt somebody's sleep and then let it
is that on an outcome but you can't
improve for example one particular
outcome and then look at the effects of
that on sleep does that make sense
absolutely yeah absolutely if you're
looking at something like diet and sleep
then you can you could do an
intervention in which some people
consume a specific meal three hours
before sleep for a period of time and
then cross them over into another group
in which they can seem different meal
and look at the effects of that on their
sleep it's just that if he sat if you
have something like mood then that's a
much more difficult construct to try and
get that incredibly subjective right
yeah that's right
very much so so we've touched on sort of
short and medium term affective of sleep
what about when we're talking over a
lifetime for someone who potentially
does shift work or has got chronic is
chronically under slept what are the
sort of things that can happen there and
then conversely what are the effects of
someone who's sleeping well over that
period yeah so over a lifetime the best
days that we have really those types of
observational data and if you look for
example at obesity there
and people who report sleeping less than
I think seven hours per night are at
forty five percent higher odds of
developing obesity later in their life
that's based on results from
meta-analysis which is a study of
studies which was published last year
that's of it that's seven hours which I
think for a lot of people would they'd
consider well you know only one hour off
eight and eight or I'm supposed to get
yeah yeah exactly and of course it they
could be misreporting but when you're
speaking about in this instance eleven
eleven studies on nearly two hundred
thousand people and that's actually
quite persuasive recent proof in the
pudding yeah so but then there are also
lots of other conditions that you could
you could look at so you're at the Janet
new neurodegenerative diseases like
Alzheimer's or dementia and again you
see that same type of Association is
there an increased risk there is an
increased risk with people who report
poor sleep yeah absolutely and there are
different ways in which we can think
about poor sleep too so in this
conversation so far we've mostly focused
on sleep duration but also there's of
course sleep efficiency so let's say
that you go to bed each night at 10 p.m.
and you wake up at 6 a.m.
you're in bed for eight hours you're not
going to be asleep the entire time it's
the inefficient it's the proportion of
that sleep period in which you are
actually asleep
so there's efficiency there there's also
sleep architecture the way you cycle
through the different stage of sleep
there are specific sleep disorders of
course of which there are over 100 best
asleep timing and something that's gain
more attention recently is sleep timing
variability so consistent consistency in
when people go to bed and wake up does
seem to be important it's a problem
regardless regardless of duration and
quality just an upset in the regular
cycle of the sleep times of sleeping and
waking yeah I think regardless of
duration I'm not sure that I would say
regardless of quality
is actually when go to sleep influence
the quality of that sleep uh-huh
that's relate to the way that sleep is
regulated and I can I can just speak
briefly about that if you like I'd love
you to speak deeply about it as I know
that a lot of the guys who I work with
to give you tiny little bit of
background my job as a club promoter
means that if i I've tracked my sleep
for around about 1300 nights using the
sleep cycle app on my phone and if you
look at the data the variability that
you have in my sleep and sleeping and
waking time is almost 24 it's almost
global it's almost 24 hours that very
regularly throughout the week I'll go to
bed when I don't have work around about
11 o'clock or 12 o'clock and get up at
sort of between anywhere between 6 & 8
but then when I go to work I'll be
working until 3:00 in the morning I'll
get home got a bed at 4 wake up at 10 or
wake up at 12 and you know this is I'm
only one person out of a massive a
massive nightlife industry then add in
shift workers and you know all manner of
other people there's a huge a huge
proportion of the population that this
will affect I'm gonna guess yeah
absolutely and if you look at shift
white for instance and that is a form of
shift work across yeah roughly twenty
percent of people and Europe and North
America do shift work and it doesn't
just affect those people it affects
their loved ones too so you have all the
second hand shift workers you have to
tolerate you Porsche for I could see you
do that work and it's really important
my way can you wake the missus up when
you get in at 4:00 a.m. and then that's
right yeah yeah
so why the effect on on shift work and
what are the effects of variable
sleeping and waking times on long short
and long-term health yeah so shift work
if you look at all of the studies that
have been done and then compile those
results then it's associated with all
sorts of native outcomes as you might
imagine well forgive it Late Late to me
frankly doctor tell me what it is if you
look at the strength of those
associations and it varies depending on
the outcome but chip work night shift
work specifically is associated with
things like obesity diabetes heart
disease risk
stroke breast cancers received some
attention certainly some cancers have
stronger evidence than others I think
that whether its associated with breast
cancer has come into question recently
because there was a large report that
was published that suggests that might
not be the case but almost everything
does seem to be effect the question is
that the question is what what is it
about shiftwork that predisposes people
to that because it's a complex exposure
scenario which it's not just sleep
that's disrupted or circadian rhythms
that are disrupted you also have people
doing all of these things and often
working stressful jobs for example that
will also affect their risk of various
diseases so that's all that's all
important to understand one thing just
to circle back to why when you sleep
affects the quality of your sleep is
that if we look at how sleep is
regulated then there are two processes
and one of those processes influences
how awake you feel at any given time
that's regulated by your circadian
system and what happens is that each day
you wake up in the morning and then over
the course the day you see this increase
in the drive to stay awake and then
around the time that you'd normally fall
asleep there's a sudden drop in this
wakefulness drive the other process is
the sleep process and that's process
that builds with prolonged wakefulness
so the longer the even awake the more
sleepy that you are and that's not a
perfectly linear effect but that's true
to some degree and there are various
physiological currents of that and these
are called saamne jhin's you can think
of them as chemical parameters of how
long you've been awake so as I'm having
this conversation with you these are
accumulating in our brains right now and
they're increasing our pressure to fall
asleep some regions yeah of some exactly
and if you look at shift work then let's
say that somebody does a slam shift so
they're used to being up during the week
and then they have a single night shift
they get in at 5:00 a.m. and for the
last five days they've been waking up at
6:00 a.m. what that means is that
whereas at 10:00 p.m. the previous
evening they had the sudden drop in
weight from his drive and they were
desperately trying to stay awake at the
start of their nightshift
now at this time they at which they're
trying to fall asleep they're just
starting to enter a period where the
wakefulness Drive is increasing so if
there's sort of a lag but with the this
sleepiness there's some najin's and the
the wakefulness drive there's a lag
behind what's actually going on
it's got like a delay on it for it to
catch up so there's this there's now
this big pressure to sleep because of
the accumulation of these halogens in
the brain but they missed that
opportunity to sleep the time in which
the wakefulness drive was very low so
they've got this combination of an
increasing drive to be awake but also
very high sleep pressure and for that
reason it's not it's not quite as easy
to fall asleep as it would have been
otherwise but let's say they do fall
asleep what will happen is that as they
enter see if the wakefulness Drive is
still increasing and they're starting to
pay off all that sleep that they've
accumulated so as somebody falls asleep
all of those saamne genes that are
accumulating in the brain are then paid
off back to normal levels so over the
course of the good nights of sleep what
should happen is that the brain is
restored you wake up next day and you've
got a big increase in alertness because
you now have an increasing wake from
Australia and you've paid off all of the
sleep debt the problem is that now these
people they're going to sleep at 6:00 in
the morning and they're starting to pay
off or that's the penis from the
previous day but they've got this
wakefulness Drive which is kicking back
in so now they're experiencing an
increasingly strong weight drive and
less and less the pressure what happens
they can't stay asleep so maybe they get
a couple of hours into the sleep episode
and they just can't consolidate it yeah
absolutely
I can certainly attest to that yeah
that's the sleep fragments and if you
pull an all-nighter and don't even try
to go to sleep let's say that you just
you go out and you're promoting your
event and getting it you just think I'm
not sleeping tonight what you can
experience over the next day is that how
sleepy you are doesn't just build
predictive
over the course of that day it watches
and wanes yeah it comes in waves yeah
and and around lunchtime we have this
so-called post lunch slump and I think a
lot of people start clear thought that
that's the results of beating a big
heavy lunch and that's not really the
case is that what's dessert there's an
argument that this is due to an
evolutionary biphasic sleep tradition is
that right or there's some people who
have claimed that yeah there are some
people who have claimed that and you do
see that in certain groups of people who
haven't been affected by the effects of
industrialization yet so if you look at
the hands of hunter-gatherers for
example then what you see with them is
that during the winter they have
monophasic sleep so all of their sleep
has consolidated and one nocturnal bout
each night but during the summer they
have a siesta so a Spanish if the
Spanish have got it right well it's
quite interesting in the Spain is a lot
warmer than somewhere like the UK and
the Spanish had their siestas at
lunchtime when it's hot they get out of
the Sun and they take advantage of that
post lunch lump and meanwhile it's not
quite so hot here and we carry on about
our working days so anyway some people
do seem to naturally have that pattern I
think if you're consistently in the
habit of sleeping in that way then it's
a perfectly healthy way to go but also
what I would say is that if you're not
used to a particular pattern then during
that lunchtime nap you will see a
reduction in the preference of sleep as
you fall asleep and what that means is
that when you then try to fall asleep
that evening you might have a harder
time nodding off yeah I could I can
definitely attest to that as well so to
give you some this is this is probably
like patient zero for bad sleep for you
but I'll I'll give you the example
anyway very typically for me if I've got
a long day in the office followed by a
trip to Manchester from Newcastle to run
one of our events I'll wake up at maybe
I'll try and push my waking time a
little bit further back so I wake up at
9:00 I'll work and then I have to drive
back for a Manchester to Newcastle I'll
go to bed at 6:00 a.m. and then looking
at my clock I'll think to myself
24 hours from now I'm gonna want to be
getting up because it'll be a Monday and
I want to start my week on a good note
but that means that at 6 a.m. on Sunday
morning I need to fall asleep wake up
fall asleep and wake up in the space of
24 hours and you know as much as like
getting up and getting after it can be
viewed as an admirable quality in a 21st
century corporate society where you know
everyone's trying to be successful it
doesn't sound like that's the best thing
for for my health it probably isn't it's
unavoidable in that particular scenario
so the question is what you do to cope
with that sleep loss and I think that
what you try to focus on is getting some
sleep and coping with the sleep loss
during the way but doing so in such a
way that you don't interfere with your
ability to fall asleep the following
evening and another thing to consider is
that you can try and preemptively
prepare for those episodes by banking
sleep beforehand so
banking is an apt analogy hearing that
let's say that you're trying to
accumulate a certain amount of wealth in
the coming week and each minute of sleep
that you get represents 1 1 pound ok
this week you try to to bank as many
pounds as possible by getting as many
minutes of sleep as possible knowing
that next week you're not going to get
that much sleep and subsequently next
week you're gonna be in debt so that
that's how you try to prepare for it so
with you Chris let's say that you've got
a really good week this week and you can
you can try to be consistent in your
patterns knowing that next week you've
got several events that will help
protect you in certain ways against the
negative effects of the sleep loss that
you will experience next week that's
really so it is it is literally like a
savings account well it is if you have a
history of incomplete sleep so let's
just say that there's a fairy tale
scenario which somebody's always let
perfectly yeah that person couldn't
necessarily Bank sleep because they
don't have any sleep that from their
previous life yeah
however that person doesn't exist as far
as far as I can tell at least and for
that reason we probably all have
something of asleep that to pay off and
banking although it might not be the
case that it's technically possible it
is effective nonetheless in terms of
what we're trying to achieve so you
could would you aim to push maybe an
extra half an hour or an extra hour for
the couple of days preceding a late
night yeah I'd go about in a few
different ways and I think the one thing
that's important to recognize is that
trying to force yourself to just go to
bed earlier might be a fool's errand the
reason is that the wake drive that I
mentioned before is at its highest just
before you try to fall asleep in some
sleep researchers refer to that as the
Forbidden Zone for sleep just have a
really hard time falling asleep at that
particular time that's lying awake
staring at the ceiling right that's
exactly right yet so so what you would
do then is thanks you try to shift your
body's internal clock your circadian
system a bit earlier and you do that by
exposing yourself to lots and lots of
bright light early and they perhaps
doing some exercise early in the day too
and then trying to reduce your nighttime
light exposure and starting your sleep
routine a little bit earlier okay so
that's that's one way of intervening
another thing is to address your
caffeine intake so while you're trying
to bank sleep trying to taper that or
maybe go cold turkey and but don't do it
to me correct please because no are you
killing me Kathy needs an adenosine
receptor antagonist so one of the
solutions which we spoke about earlier
is been Essene which the breakdown
products of ATP so as your brain expends
energy during the day it releases ATP
from presynaptic neurons into the
extracellular fluid that bathes brain
cells okay and this ATP can act directly
on sleep circuits and the brains promote
sleep it can dis inhibit sorry it can
inhibit weight promoting circuits - or
the ATP can be broken down
to adenosine and that can also have
similar effects and anyway
caffeine blocks the interaction of that
adenosine with its reset it binds to the
same receptor right so basically you've
got all of this it that's exactly what
it does so you put all the sleep in a
signal but it's like somebody shouting
and there are no ears there to hear the
person shouting okay so avoid avoid
caffeine for those couple of days try
and get yourself try and get yourself up
and get moving so you you're almost
artificially you're artificially moving
the day light a little bit earlier in
the day and then closing the sunset off
a little bit earlier as well yeah and
then try and avoid waking to an alarm if
possible during that time and you can
also use banks to try to that's right
you can also try to use naps to Bank
sleep during the day if you're if you're
very short on sleep during that time
when you're trying to bounce the and
using a nap during the post lunch lump
can be useful okay well that's a that's
a really cool really cool little bit of
advice there so I want to we've we've
touched on the effects of sleep and and
how important it is I want to talk about
enhancing your circadian system function
and sleep and then also how we can cope
with with sleep loss and then we're
going to finish on the finish on some
stuff to do with human OS so if you were
to write a prescription for someone who
wanted to have as good sleep as they
could have you got some principles that
they should be sticking to yeah many
principles and I think that it's worth
starting with the daytime so during the
day you want to be physically active and
the reason that comes back to adenosine
in the fact that as you burn more energy
you accumulate more adenosine and and
then that helps you sleep more deeply at
night during the day you also want to
expose yourself to lots of bright light
and because the amount of energy that
your brain burns you want to do
cognitively demanding work and also that
can include other activity so things
like meditation are actually quite
taxing and do consistently improve sleep
not just because of an effect
but also because they probably have
roles on things like stress regulation
to her a sympathetic nervous system and
stuff like that right that's right yeah
and then during the night time I think
that it's valuable for somebody who's
not in a very consistent pattern to set
an alarm in anticipation at their
bedtime so let's say that your sleep
routine takes you an hour then you would
set your alarm for an hour before
bedtime
yeah regarding your bedroom itself you
want to make it stress-free so keep it
uncluttered and use it for sleep and sex
only and then lights exposure is really
really important so do they get outside
lots and lots of bright lights and then
probably around two hours before you
intend to go to bed you want to start
reducing your light exposure and where
possible I would avoid artificial
lighting but I know that that's often
not possible so what can do in those
circumstances you can use apps on your
devices so things like Twilight for
Android systems or night shift mode for
iPhones you can use f dot Lux on your
laptop which is on mine right now you
can also use things like blue blocking
glasses I don't personally use them I
just don't have the self confidence when
getting in there Ben Greenfield
territory with blue blocking glasses
aren't we yeah a little bit
no there's that T and then as we fall
asleep by these black outlines in your
bedroom good curtains or just use a
sleep mask is there a is is there any
substance to photo receptors in your
skin being able to detect light in sure
I I don't think so there was a paper
that was published in the journal
Science in 1997 which received a lot of
airtime this was the kind of Journal
article that would get on the front page
of the Washington Post because it was
novel but it wasn't replicated and what
they did is they Sean lights on the back
of somebody's knee I think and and
supposedly it was able to shift the
timing of the circadian system okay now
it hasn't been shown since Oh
as far as I'm aware that's not the case
I know that there are these devices now
that do things like shine bright lights
in your ears yeah there's all kind of
weird and wonderful sleep aids now isn't
there yeah and and not just for sleep
because light actually has a variety of
other effects the non-image forming
effects but effects that are either
relates to the circadian system or they
have effects on things like cognition so
bright light exposure during the daytime
routine evil acutely boosts someone's
mental performance if they haven't been
exposed to bright light before that and
that's why actually one of the ways they
coat that sneak losses and come to you
is making sure that you spend some time
outside so that is part of the picture
but these devices anyway the shine
they're shining light in your ears yeah
I'm I'm not sure about them I haven't
look close at the research you don't
have a pair I don't have a pair no and I
I'm not aware of any sleep researchers
that seem particularly persuaded by
their utility I'll put it that way okay
so I mean there's it's definitely um
going back to a couple of Ben Greenfield
podcasts that I've heard and a few other
anecdotal bits of evidence people that
go into hotel rooms and will put tape
over microwave and air conditioning LEDs
and stuff like that because even if
they've got a they've got the sleep mask
with them they're not happy with the
darkness of the room yeah I I think that
a lot of that is overkill is that
sweating the small stuff it's sweating
the small stuff from the point actually
is that these photoreceptors in your eye
that are involved in the regulation of
your SCADA system are quite sluggish
they they keep a track record of your
light exposure over the course of the
day they don't respond very acutely to
it so if you spend lots of time outside
during the daytime had lots of bright
lights exposure which is a verb blue
wavelength in particular then a little
bit of light exposure at night from a
microwave there's a drop in the ocean
yeah it just won't shift
system with that said if you'd been in
complete darkness for the previous 16
hours and then you went to the toilet
and you switch the lights on when you
went to the toilet then that actually
probably would shift the phase of your
scanning system that's interesting so
you kind of become your sensitivity to
light is increased based on what the the
most recent period of your day has been
like strongly so yeah that's crazy
that's a guess for people in certain
professions that's going to be a very
important fact for them to take away
yeah it has strong implications for the
shift work and for things like jet lag
too because you have situations in which
you want to go to [ __ ] work for instance
but just there for one evening to adapt
so did you refer to refer to that as a
slam shift yeah yeah and you've got all
these different shift work schedules and
in some instances particularly remote
environments people will want to go
somewhere and they will always be on
night shift and in those rare
circumstances you want to fully adapt
your circadian system and all you do
then is you manipulate your environment
such that we make that as easy as
possible and you don't go outside that's
that's not most people yes so the
question in those situations is how do
you go to work maintain vigilance during
that time but not screw yourself up too
much in the long term in the days to
come with with difficulty it sounds so
we've got we've got the black up lines
we've tried to expose ourselves to light
during the day we've had our I guess
what you would what commonly referred to
as a digital sunset that two-hour period
before you going to sleep starting to
reduce your light exposure specifically
to blue light which is what's emitted
from things like phones and iPods and
TVs and laptops and stuff like that if
you do have to use them use a hewing
program which is night mode on on an
iPhone or similar similar application
elsewhere what about sleep posture and
the temperature and the sleep
environment that you're actually laid on
did you have you looked into this much
yeah I looked at temperature pushes
interesting and I it's fun eh I'm
interviewing a guy for our podcast
stuart mcgill who's arguably the world's
foremost expert in spine biomechanics in
a few days time and i'm curious to hear
his thoughts on that i think that the
best sleeping posture is likely highly
dependent on the person probably most
probably the most comfortable one right
surprise surprise so but anyway some
people spines are very flexion
intolerant if they bend over to tie
their shoes or whatever if they sit at a
desk all day then their spines really
don't like being in that position so you
keep them there back over time might not
be wise other people are very extension
intolerant so if they arch back and look
up at the ceiling then they experience
pain as a fascinating people like
gymnasts and for those people sleeping
on the front is gonna be unwise i think
for most people sneaking on the side is
probably smart and i generally find that
people often benefit from having a
pillow between the knees during sleep to
something between their knees just to
keep them slightly ajar and i suspect
that's related to the spine but i don't
actually know what the mechanism is it's
just that many people seem to be more
comfortable in that position but you and
mr. McGill will hopefully find that out
by the time that we've published this I
think yours will be up as well so I'll
make sure that I'll link that in the
show notes for the listeners who want to
go and do some further reading or
further further listening it should be
so how about temperature yes the
temperature is interesting in that what
we want to do is raise the temperature
of the skin by a couple of degrees
shortly before sleep and this is
counterintuitive because during sleep
the temperature of your brain drops as
you progress into deepest late stages of
sleep so during deep sleep it's at its
lowest and then during REM sleep as the
metabolic activity in your brain rise it
goes up again it's not just as a is that
as a byproduct of the activity or is
that yeah it is it is partly a byproduct
objectivity but things that you can do
to facilitate that drop yeah so help you
fall asleep
by raising the temperature of your skin
you create this gradient between your
core temperature deep within you and the
temperature of your brain and the
temperature of your skin and that helps
you radiate heat out from your core
improving your ability to drop the
temperature of your core and your brain
so a simple way to achieve that is a hot
shower typically about 10 minutes at
about 40 degrees C is about right within
maybe an hour of when you go to bed and
then the parts of your body are also
relevant to because your hands and your
feet and from your ears too are
relatively unique in their structure
they have a very big surface area but
not such a big body and that makes them
very effective at transferring Heat the
environment that the body's the body's
radiators right yeah so when you get out
of the shower you want to keep your feet
warm so stick some socks on and that
seems to consistently how people both
fall asleep faster stay asleep and
perhaps sleep a little bit longer too
there's been some research published on
that in the last few months by keeping
by keeping the socks on yeah well in
that instance there was actually using
these special socks though the feet
slightly during sleep ok so all of the
all of the girlfriends that are
listening who absolutely hate their
boyfriends going to sleep in socks
they're actually they actually need to
side sideline their concerns about
fashion and focus more on the fact that
that potentially getting a little bit
better sleep they need to stick their
sleep masks on yeah and then they can't
see the socks yes we found the solution
so you've had the hot shower before you
go to bed and that is going to help you
radiate heat away right from your core
yeah but then of course you don't want
the surrounding temperature to be too
high and you want your bedding to let
you continue to lose heat so needs to be
able to effectively transfer heat and I
know there are some companies out there
that say that their sheets are better
than other sheets are doing this I would
just like
but there are a couple of companies
aren't familiar with one of them is
called sheiks and you know a good name
for a sheet company absolutely and you
can look into those but anyway the point
is that you don't want your bedroom to
be too warm you also don't want it to be
very cold because again thinking about
evolution if the environment if the
environmental temperature was very hot
or very cold then that's a stressor to
the body and it's a signal that you
don't want to hang around because
otherwise you're going to disrupt your
ability to regulate your internal
environment and for that reason the
bedroom needs to be comfortable but cool
so you would err on the side of cooler
than warmer I would yeah and actually
one thing I love is using a fan because
yeah it serves two purposes it keeps you
cool I would a Matt your torso and also
it's a form of white noise so if you're
in a relatively busy place and it just
drowns out worthy extraneous
disturbances that could otherwise wake
you up from sleep well I'm glad that
you've actually hit upon one habit that
I've had for about seven years which is
a tiny little steel desk fan which is
next to my bed and I've kept kept with
me since uni and yeah that's I couldn't
attest to that more it's nice to have
the breeze and also you totally right
about the white noise in the background
especially if my sleep patterns been
thrown out a little bit and I'm trying
to then sleep through a morning where
I've got housemates that might be moving
around and cars going up and down
outside yeah it's definitely a double
whammy on that front
yeah so what else can we do to enhance
sleep or our circadian system function
okay so just thinking this the couple of
things one is relates diet so I spoke
about Kathleen broody food earlier I
would just say caffeine typically is
metabolized relatively slowly and for
that reason you don't want to consume
too late in the day as an arbitrary
cutoff I would say try to not consume
caffeine any later than about nine hours
before you plan to fall asleep or
that is that is potentially very early
for a lot of people isn't it well it's
it's it's gonna be hard for the shift
workers in particular yeah but I I think
also the caffeine is something that when
you go through the initial period of
cutting your caffeine intake it sucks
many people have and it's but it passes
and over time as your sleep quality
improves the nice thing also is that you
become more sensitive to caffeine again
yeah so you need less so you net a
benefit on a number of different front
yeah exactly and then when you do use it
for those night shifts infrequently it
has a very strong alerting effect on you
so you improve your sleep you feel
terrible for a couple of days when
you're over the hump it's all good
so anyway I'd say no more than about two
milligrams of caffeine per kilogram of
body mass so if you're 80 kilos then
that's a bit more than a coffee I know
that's not an awful lot but that by nine
hours before bed
the half the half-life is is it tails
off very slowly doesn't it I like about
six hours yeah and the hop for listeners
is just the amount of time that it takes
for the caffeine concentration in your
blood stream to reach half of the peak
value the experience after consuming the
caffeine so another thing is alcohol and
a lot of people use alcohol as a
sedative and alcohol does reduce the
amount of time that it takes people to
fall asleep and increase the amount of
deep sleep that people get early in the
night but then later in the evening as
your liver clears the alcohol your body
tries to frenetically try and catch up
on the last rapid eye movement sleep and
what tends to happen is you have these
bizarre dreams and your sleep also
fragments so the quality of your sleep
is reduced I think this is something
from that I'd read with Matthew Walker's
book which is the important distinction
between sleep and sedation when using
substances to assist you I think the
same came up with regards to marijuana
yeah that's right and many sleep drugs
are hypnotics so they put you in a more
suggestive state and you can you can
fall asleep more easily from but they
don't necessarily produce physiological
sleep it's time under the time under the
curve that you're after right not just
the planting the flag in the ground of I
am no longer awake yeah yeah and it's a
it's a real issue and actually for
people who struggle with sleep one thing
that I always say is that if you have
insomnia the first port of call is
always CBT i cognitive behavioral
therapy for insomnia if you're in the UK
and you have insomnia then i think that
the NHS will subsidize an online CBT
program and what it is is a sleep
education modules teaching about the pi
gene it's very effective very very
effective and it's as it effective
online as it is in person to so go that
route before you touch any of the sleep
drugs i think sleep drugs occasionally
have their place so let's say that chris
you fly out to Hawaii yeah and you're
there for two days and by the time you
go to bed that evening it's the time at
which you would normally wake up back
home and there's no wave you're gonna
fall asleep yeah
in that instance I personally wouldn't
mind taking a small amount of one of the
over-the-counter sleep aids that you can
take do you have a do you have a list of
ones that are um dr. Greg Potter
approved I'm not going there
do you do you have a list of ones which
you use or would use well this is an
advice not advice okay to be incredibly
clear to everyone who's listening this
is a hypothetical situation this is not
advice and it's so probably actually not
what I would take if I had access to
sleep drugs because many of them are
only available under subscription okay
I'm a prescription sorry yeah so you can
get diphenhydramine over-the-counter
which is just the stuff that's in
it--all and that is what's called an
inverse agonist that histamine h1
receptors in the brain it just means
that instead of just blocking the
interaction of histamine with its
receptors histamine is a weight
promoting urine modulator
and they're just blocking that
interaction it actually has the opposing
effect and diphenhydramine seems to help
you before us these global faster and
there's the slightly longer and it is
available over-the-counter the
recommended dose is fifty milligrams in
the research you really buy it in twenty
five milligram tablets now say start
with that and increase your dose up to a
maximum fifty milligrams so I think that
can be useful the problem with all these
things is that when you target one
particular neuromodulator in that way
you can quickly produce pens and we're
told
see yeah actually it's funny because
there's a discordance between people's
perceptions of natural substances and
medications so people will often resort
to herbal sleep aids thinking oh it's
natural it must be safe if they're
targeting the same chemical pathways in
the brain then just because something is
from a plant it doesn't mean that it's
magically gonna be okay and that it's
it's gonna have fewer negative
consequences then it's synthetic
counterpart the potential for it to
carry along with it some byproducts that
might have unintended consequences as
well is probably a little bit higher
than something that's been synthesized
purely for the purpose of being that
that particular pure compound how well
regulated is the supplement industry
incredibly not but the drug industry is
also well debatably but at least a
little bit more I think yeah so what
about I'm gonna touch on it because I
was recently in America and this is this
seems so widespread I knew that was
gonna have a sit-down with you so I
wanted to ask some people of a group of
five men and 10 women that was sat
around a table with which is definitely
not a representative sample but 10 out
of the 15 of them all use melatonin
every night and all of them reported
using the tablets at least a couple of
times per year okay the tablets that
they were referring to mostly were
sublingual ones which dissolve
the tongue I know that melatonin isn't
available in the UK so this may be a
supplement that a lot of people who are
listening have never tried
have you had a look at much research to
do with melatonin uh I guess it's
external melatonin or yeah I have well
find chats on our PhD was was on this
topic oh well you should you should know
a little bit about with them yeah I
retain that but but anyway that's that's
interesting what you're saying is that
those people take it when they're at
home on local time but they think that
it helps their sleep exactly that and
multiple multiples of this group were
combining that with wine and of that a
smaller subsection we're combining it
with wine and weed yeah so so
polypharmacy isn't smart and and I don't
recall the specific interactions for
melatonin I think that it competes with
caffeine so so anyway melatonin is
metabolized by the liver by some
cytochrome enzyme so I think people
fifty and there are various other
xenobiotics so just foreign compounds
chemicals that are metabolized by that
same enzyme and what that means is that
if you take it at the same time
something else then often the melatonin
ends up being broken down far less
efficiently than it would be ways to
take it by itself so you definitely
shouldn't be drinking and melatonin it's
just a weird combination tea well Bing
Bing Bing Frank you know if that's the
worst thing that the people sat around
the table were taking from America it's
it's potentially not it's certainly not
as bad as some of the some of the
stories that you hear coming out but so
it could be an awful lot worse yeah
actor melatonin as a sleep aid yes I I
think that it's useful for helping
people to synchronize their circadian
systems when the circadian system is
misaligned
so jet lag or adaptations chronic shift
work great perfect news case in re
with very old people sometimes they
experience things like calcification of
the pineal gland and in general their
circadian rhythms become more disruptive
more disrupted at many levels are we
talking sixty plus seventy plus it's
it's like anything else if you look at
the loss of skeletal muscle mass with
age or decline in cardiorespiratory
fitness it's a gradual process okay it's
not like there's some sharp cutoff but
they could probably could be with some
disease states but that said okay so yes
as you see these dampening of circadian
rhythms with age I think that those
people would sometimes benefit from
melatonin and there's a little bit of
evidence to that end too so for example
there's been work on people with
insomnia who are also elderly taking a
slow-release form of melatonin called
circadian 2 milligrams and it seems to
help those people maintain their sleep
over the course of the evening there's
also some work on postmenopausal women
and the effects of taking melatonin over
the course of a year looking at bone
mineral density in particular and body
composition and actually melatonin
seemed to increase bone mineral density
and reduced fat mass so at the end of
the year their weight was relatively
stable but the composition of that
weight had improved yeah okay so with
those elderly people I think that it can
be useful but but for most of us who
have relatively well functioning
circadian systems I don't see it as
being very useful I personally would use
it at a 5 milligram dose during jet lag
jet lag being when you traveled from
across at least three time zones uh-huh
and I take in about two hours before bed
typically and you can use it
preemptively too so if you want to help
you start preparing to adjust to a
different time zone in advance of flying
out there then you can take it in the
days before so let's say that you want
to fly three time zones to the east and
you'll need to wake up earlier and go to
bed earlier
you can start taking melatonin
progressively earlier in the days before
ya starts well let's start to align
yourself with the time zone that you're
moving to before you get there yes I
think I think that's useful okay and
then shift shift work potentially as
well
chronic shift work yes to help stabilize
their patterns because it's just so easy
people that consistently work night
shifts to finish up and then start
driving home and ah the sun's coming up
and it's coming up at exactly the wrong
time either
yeah it's irregular when I'm driving
back from Manchester if it's during the
summer that I'll need to put my
sunglasses on because I'm driving down
in the Sun setting and then around about
3:30 or 4:00 a.m. I'll need to put my
sunglasses back on because the sunrise
is hitting me in the face since I'm
trying to get at home yeah well smart
that's exactly what you should be doing
in your sunglasses on yeah
well making sure that you stay awake and
of course prison shouldn't be driving
drowsy I'm not sure yeah but I also
can't have you've told me that I can't
have caffeine up to ideally up to nine
hours before bed in the half-life six
hours but my usual plan of necking a
monster three hours before I get home
which is the exact time that the journey
takes me is um I'm kind of fighting it's
an immovable object an unstoppable force
here isn't it well what I'll add is
before we just return to melatonin you
can take a very brief nap and actually
to have the biggest short-term effect on
your alertness all you need is a
10-minute nap if you take a longer nap
then you start to progress into deeper
stages of sleep and the issue is that is
that as you go into deep sleep you had
this sleep inertia or afterwards so you
wake up and you feel drowsy yeah you
have this later boost in alertness which
is actually ultimately the greater man
achieve them in the short in short a nap
but if you just want a brief nap and
something that's going to give you the
kind of increase in the lightness that
you get from the caffeine ten minutes by
the side of the road if you stop off
will give you much the same effect and
it won't impair your ability to fall to
eat later either that's faster that's
fantastic so hello I know that my
business partner Darrin will be
listening he he absolutely loves I think
Weatherby services
Scotch corner his two favorite spots on
the a1 so you know you've got it right
by I think he takes one of his socks off
and drapes it across his eyes if it's
too bright that's I'm not sure how how
scientifically accurate using a sock for
a face mask is but it needs must I
suppose so going back to the melatonin
use do you think then a lot of the
dependence on this is just that it's a
psychological dependence rather than a
physiological one well there's lots of
interesting preclinical by which I mean
Studies on animals research that's been
done showing all of these positive
effects of melatonin on various outcomes
there's actually a journal called the
journal at pineal research and
everything in that Journal more or less
is about melatonin and melatonin does
all sorts of cool things to other
animals you give them a fattening diet
melatonin reduces the fattening effects
of that diet you induced diabetes
temporarily melatonin protects against
the development of diabetes or helps
reverse it so with that in mind I think
a lot of people have looked at some of
this early research and thought oh well
melatonin seems innocuous
there's no think it's a panacea yeah I
suppose what I will say is that it is
remarkably safe melatonin and whereas
the other sleep aids that people take
will lead that kind of tolerance and
withdrawal effects that I mentioned
melatonin is unusual so it doesn't
really seem to have that effect so if
you for example as a guy take
testosterone then there's this negative
feedback cycle you have this exogenous
or for outside the body testosterone
that's floating around in bud stream and
your body will naturally shut down its
own production to help you maintain
relatively normal levels within your
bloodstream but with melatonin that's
not really the case if you take
melatonin from the outside and actually
a calm melatonin taste let's say two
milligrams that would produce melatonin
levels in your blood which is orders of
magnitude higher than the natural levels
that you would produce and actually
there are some people who have
absolutely no detectable melatonin in
their blood
they at anytime and they sleep okay so
melatonin whereas people think about it
as a sleep hormones isn't really asleep
all night if you take in those big doses
then it does reduce core body
temperature and help people fall asleep
a little bit faster and you do sometimes
see that effect in healthy people but
apart from that the effects on the team
to be quite negligible and there's also
some emerging evidence now that
melatonin does play roles in metabolism
as you'd expect because it's carrying
this nighttime signal throughout the
body and in people with a particular
variance the melatonin receptor having
too much melatonin floating around at
the wrong times is not a good thing
because for example it will impair their
ability to dispose of glucose and their
blood streams effectively so with all of
that said healthy young person taking
melatonin they might fall asleep a
little bit faster that unlikely see
themselves any harm in the long term if
they have this melatonin receptor Varian
then it might be contraindicated but
save your money and spend that on
something more fun or more valuable to
you how yeah so I would save the money
on that tub of melatonin or something
similar and buy a pair of blackout
blinds much smarter okay just because
we're on to draw a line into substances
compounds like 5-htp and other Devery
very popular have you had a look at
anything to do with that I have yeah but
not not this year actually I did until
about December last year a relatively
close look at the literature on all
sleep supplements so some of the herbs
that are out there various amino acids
so 5-htp tryptophan glycine there are
all sorts of ones that we've looked at
and what does the research say about
them
tryptophan might be the most interesting
to me other than glycine we'll come back
to glycine so tryptophan there was a lot
of research on in the 1980s or so and
it's a precursor to melatonin ultimately
but fire serotonin okay and it's funny
because people want thought the
serotonin moszer's sleep hormone and
it's not it's actually the exact
opposite it depends on the part of the
brain that you're looking at but in
general wake causes coma
yeah serotonin is involved in
wakefulness so taking trip to found the
view towards increasing melatonin levels
doesn't make that much sense if it needs
to go by a serotonin but anyway some of
those early research studies on
tryptophan did show some effects on
sleep
I don't recall the specific soft-top
Amanda I think people might have fallen
asleep slightly faster and they they
were there were some well-done studies
to people using polysomnography which is
where you measure things like the
electrical activity in someone's brain
and their eye movements and that gives
you the most objective measure of
difference the sleep stage the people
cycle through yes
so tryptophan is interesting but there
hasn't been the kind of rigor in the
research that I would want to see before
I would recommend it glycine is
interesting for various reasons not just
related to sleep and I think the glycine
is relatively benign so all these things
that you can take and it's unlikely to
hurt you guys seen might help with sleep
by binding to receptors in the master
clock in the brain and by doing so it
actually increases peripheral
vasodilation so blood flow to your
extremities and by doing so it increases
that radiator effect that we just like
core temperature manipulation again yeah
it facilitates that drop and there have
been a couple of studies showing that
taking glycine helps people fall asleep
faster and sleeps like longer again the
quality of that research isn't that high
but if you look at the
Effects of glycine and other things
that's being studied for things like
lifespan extension and also joint
integrity then I wouldn't really
hesitate to recommend that the other
thing is that the amino acid composition
of most people's diets now it's probably
quite different from our distant
ancestors in them once ate nose to tail
people nowadays don't really and the
majority of meat people eat is muscle
meat and for that reason they miss out
on the types of all the same proportions
of amino acids that they once would have
got in their diets eating in a more
natural way and lies there's one of
those amino acids that they maybe skimp
on Oh interesting
I wouldn't hesitate to try glycine it
also tastes like sugar and you can take
3 grams of that about an hour before
bedtime and see if it helps
ok it's very cheap to you like I
recommend that before taking melatonin
fantastic ok well we've got some nice
some nice bits to follow there so I want
to ask I you've mentioned this this word
earlier on I've got no idea what it
means what chrono nutrition yeah so
pronoun nutrition is the study of the
interactions between your diet and your
body's clock so how for example does
when you eat influence the timing of the
various clocks in your circadian system
or what are the implications of when
your circadian system is best prepared
for various activities on when you
should eat ok
it's that reciprocal relationship I
understand so we're going to go on to
ways to enhance circadian system
function and Crona nutrition ties in
quite nicely here is the would you how
highly would you place Crona nutrition
on the list of ways to enhance your
circadian system function
I would for most people I would say that
it's probably quite important it's a
very nascent area of study
there aren't many researchers that have
spent many years looking at it but so
far the evidence is very interesting and
I don't think that many people think
about it and for that reason it might be
a low-hanging fruit everybody
historically is focused on what they
should be eating and not when they
should eat and being more consistent in
eating patterns and restricting them to
your biological daytime so not the time
of day at which your body's saying I
should be sleeping now is smart for many
reasons and there are many different
directions that we could go with this
one more thing that I'll mention is that
whereas the light-dark cycle is the mean
time key for the master clock in your
brain your diet seems to be the main
time key for many peripheral clocks by
which I just mean all of those clocks
outside the master clock in your body so
that actually means other clocks in your
brain too but the clock in your liver
and your gut and your skeletal muscles
and so on and your fatty sheet so many
people they eat in very haphazard ways
one day they wake up in the morning and
they have breakfast at 6 a.m. and they
have dinner at 10 p.m. the next day they
skip breakfast there the first meal at 1
p.m. in the afternoon and then they have
their dinner at 6 p.m. and that type of
thing consistency seems to be a bad
thing if you take people on the very
rigorous conditions and in one condition
they have a consistent number of meals
each day and in another condition they
take exactly the same food and they
distribute it into a varying number of
meals then at the end of those two
periods the people who've had the
varying number of meals for tend to burn
fewer calories in response to eating
their blood sugar regulation would be
worse and that blood lipid profiles be
worse - oh that's interesting in healthy
young women so consistency is important
another another consideration is
the duration of the caloric period and I
say caloric period because I could talk
about eating period however many people
now will have some sort of concoction
from Starbucks that has 800 calories and
they might as well be drinking a blended
lasagna or something together because
actually the same things in it you know
you have large quantities of fat in it
and calories and so on yes I think it's
more useful actually to think about the
caloric period so when am i consuming
calorie containing items and even more
useful actually to think about when am i
consuming items that aren't just water
and trying to make that consistent I was
gonna say so you dink included in color
things that are just what it would be
coffee
for instance yeah I would throw things
like coffee and tea in there even if it
was coffee without milk and sugar
because coffee contains caffeine and we
haven't really spoke about this but
caffeine per se does seem to influence
the scaley insistency at least in cells
and probably in humans too it's been
shown that if people consume caffeine
late at night then they delay their
melatonin synthesis onset in the evening
and constant conditions okay so anyway
that period probably is relevant to for
a lot of people I think consistency
might be the most important thing but
people now looking at the so-called time
restricted eating studies 16 eights or
like twenty twenty twenty fours and
stuff like that with intermittent
fasting right yeah exactly and there's
been there are a few people who are very
vocal about its benefits but actually if
you look at the entire body of
literature on the subject there just
aren't many studies points at the moment
I mean anyone who's purveyed reddit
recently will know that between
intermittent fasting and no FAP
you have like the two most militant
dogmatic cultures subcultures of people
who swear that they get superhuman
benefits from eating for hours out of 20
or eating
after 24 hours of fasting or not
touching the penis good I mean I don't
know
I wonder how many people are doing in
intermittent fasting and no FAP together
that must be a pretty miserable
existence but yeah it's um both of them
seem to be from a similar kind of camp
yeah and I I think that it it probably
is useful in some circumstances so what
does the evidence show so far it shows
that if you take people and in one
condition they're allowed to eat when
they want and in another commission they
restrict their eating period typically
what happens is the people who restrict
the eating period or the caloric period
will consume fewer calories but they'll
also expend less energy over the day so
they specifically tend to engage in less
non-exercise activity thermogenesis
which is just fidgeting and probably
take a few fewer steps each day too and
the net effect of that is that they burn
less energy they consume less energy and
therefore remain in energy balance as as
they did in the other condition in which
they just eat when they want to eat
solely but that doesn't seem to be
beneficial and there are a couple of
very nice things in showing that -
coming out of the University of Bath and
also some work from the US - so body
weight seems to be relatively unaffected
then there's blood sugar regulation if
anything skipping breakfast specifically
is one way to shorten the eating period
seems to impair your ability to regulate
your blood sugar later in the day your
blood sugar levels in response to
consuming meals are more variable and
that variability is somewhat predictive
of the development of metabolic disease
or subsequently like diabetes okay so
that's a lot of beneficial effect and
then almost everything else that's been
studied it doesn't really seem to be
having a strong effect on if anything it
seems to increase inflammatory responses
to feeding which also probably isn't a
beneficial effect am i saying that it's
never going to be useful absolutely not
but I think that these kind of
compressed eating periods are necessary
for lots of people I think that at the
moment there are too many people
jumping on the bandwagon and saying that
this is enormous the important when so
far the science doesn't really show you
that it does show you that in rodents if
you look at mice for example then it is
very protective against metabolic
disease development its longevity right
it's a 30% increase around that number
and in terms of longevity yeah all sorts
of things and one of the really
difficult things that people are only
just starting to tease apart is the
effect of restricted caloric periods as
distinct from the effects of energy
restriction because often the two bond
hand-in-hand historically yeah if you're
eating less food or is it that you're
eating within this special window yeah
and and only very recently have
researchers develop the types of methods
they need to answer those questions be
even in laboratory animals so it's gonna
be really exciting to see what the
results of some of those studies are but
anyway these types of restricted caloric
periods are really really beneficial in
other animals so far the effects on
humans don't really seem to be
particularly remarkable as far as I'm
concerned from what I've seen but I do
think that they will prove to be very
valuable for certain people in certain
circumstances thanks in the same way
that keto can be useful for people who
suffer from epilepsy for instance yeah
that's a very good analogy I think
probably actually people with things
like gastrointestinal disorders will
benefit from restricted eating periods
because you just give the whole tractor
break for a consistent period of time
which day yeah so that's that's one
example of a use case which to me makes
perfect sense so there's that and then
there are also certain circumstances in
which people are unavoidably inactive
and if they're just sat at the desk all
day and they restrict their caloric
period and they end up eating less
because they restricted it and what they
eat has
no bearing on their activity regardless
then that might be useful too so I think
that my key takeaways would be that you
don't want to eat too late at night or
as soon as you wake up in the morning
especially if you wake up to an alarm
you want to wait until shortly after you
would naturally be awake before you
start consuming anything other than
water in my opinion okay and then also
consuming late at night so let's say
within if I was going to give you an
arbitral cutoff within two hours of when
you plan to go to bed is probably
ill-advised because one of the things
that you see in response to calorie
ingestion is that your body has to use
energy to break down or those nutrients
so you call temperature rises and that's
going to noted the effect the drop in
brain temperature that's necessary to
helping you initiate sleep mm-hmm it's
um there's so many nebulous little
elements that are contributing to sleep
and the quality of sleep and then you
know earlier in the discussion we we
went through just how important it is
and why it's important to get good sleep
I think it would be quite easy for
someone who's listening to hear any of
these individual individual points in
isolation and think well you know like
do I really need to avoid IDI I really
need to do the hot shot do I really need
to have the cool room and the fan so on
and so forth do you think it's one thing
that you're going to do absolutely
everyday habit setting to clean your
teeth was done when you were a child and
now you don't think twice about it but
if I told you to do it if I told you
that you had to spend two minutes three
times a day sticking something in your
mouth and you've never done it before in
your life you think I well that's that's
probably a little bit of a pain in the
ass and you know to to look at
optimizing and drilling down to its
constituent parts a process which all of
us need to do and which we've already
identified is really crucial for
short-term performance and health and
then long-term health and longevity you
know I think the can't really be too
much weight applied to people trying to
do this is there a
you know especially with Matthew
Walker's book why we sleep it's it's
been pretty widespread can you feel a
change in the tide of the interest in
sleep and the appreciation for how
important it is in the more a wider
populous yeah there's been an enormous
shift actually and I'm grateful in a way
because it's coincided with my PhD I was
gonna say do you feel like you're riding
the crest of a wave at the moment yeah I
think so and but I don't want to sound
it could easily come across the wrong
way but anyway I had a paper published
in the second year of my PhD and the
paper is entirely unremarkable it's it's
an OK publication there was nothing
revolutionary about it whatsoever
basically found that people who sleep
less people who report sleeping less in
the UK are on average heavier have
bigger waist lines and tend to have
lower levels of HDL cholesterol it's
just a type of cholesterol that's
involved in removing fatty deposits in
your blood vessels from where they
shouldn't be
and my supervisor decided to send out a
press release on the back of that paper
and it people went absolutely nuts for
it
it was it was very very strange I was
interviewed by the BBC World Service it
was in The New York Times it was in Wow
USA Today we shocked [ __ ] I had no idea
what was going on yeah
so that's I'm not saying that to make it
out as if I did something great because
I fully recognize that I absolutely
didn't it was just fascinating to behold
it's a marker for how interested people
are becoming in sleep right yeah it's a
perfect marker for it but what what a
fantastic development because we have
spoke to people like Matt Walker who is
a fantastic scientist there are very few
people in the world if anybody in the
world who knows more about sleep and
memory specifically the Matt Walker but
he's also a great communicator so the
nice thing is that we have a handful of
people like him who are
spreading the good word about sleep and
they're actually generating a lot of
momentum and getting in front of the
people they want to be in front of and
starting to instigate some change by
raising awareness and over time more
progressive employers and so on are
starting to think more about this okay
are people sleeping better then they're
gonna spend less time absent they're
going to be more productive when they're
at work and so on so one of the things
that we can do in the workplace to make
it more conducive to having people meet
their sleep needs so the tide is
definitely there at the moment and
what's interesting is that whereas with
diet things are repackaged every few
years into another fad and the fat
itself more or less delivers the same
information in a new way okay
calorie deficit the calories eaten more
vegetables for most people is probably
smart protein helps keep you full and
don't eat pizza
if James if James Smith PT is listening
he'll be it'll be shouting at the mic at
the moment because he is the number one
proponent of dombay into fads you just
need a calorie [ __ ] deficit mate
instances of that haven't you like off
the back of what was that film with the
famous journalist who went Nate
McDonald's for a period of time
pasteurization was it supersize me sleep
besides me so he was in really bad shape
after that he was and [ __ ] and then
there was a smaller documentary by
s'more I mean in terms of the amount of
attention that it generated in response
to that in which somebody consumed fast
food for a certain period of time but
ensured that they were in an energy
deficit and almost all of the health
outcomes that they tracked and proved
over that period of time so calories are
important and there are these
fundamental things but what I was
getting at is that with diet you have
all these different
actions of people at the moment
everybody is absolutely bonkers for
Keith's genic diets yeah which
completely baffles me on a personal
level but at the same time I do
understand it and that will pass and
there'll be another one the person well
I mean you know to interject there the
the listeners will know how much I adore
Jordan Pederson and as a thinker he's
fantastic but as a dietician I would not
personally I would not take his advice
it was sat on Joe Rogan saying last a
couple of weeks ago that he'd started
the carnivore diet where he eats juice
he's cut greens out from a ketogenic
diet and was never really doing the fat
he eats steak and salt and that's it and
he was saying to Joe he was like and I
couldn't bloody believe it you know I
lost 10 pounds in the first month and
then the second runt I lost 10 pounds
and that continued every month for five
months I'm the same weight I was when I
was in college I I can't bloody believe
it like do you understand how how many
calories you're having per day Jordan
you're my fitness pal say is probably
1,500 calories or less like where did
you sit what did he think was going to
happen
your body's starving now I know that
your daughter's Emoto immune disease has
been cured absolutely fantastic and
yourself depression mood regulation all
of those things but you can't attribute
the weight loss to some magic
manipulation of the of what you're
putting in your mouth it's the fact that
you're not eating very much he said oh
my literally says two minutes after that
and you know I my home has dropped by
70% at least I'm never hungry like what
are you [ __ ] surprised your body's
starving I actually watched that just as
an aside I'm not sure if that was a
Canadian accent or that that's we trying
to do Canadian okay that's my best
Jordan Peterson
I think there's a pretty accurate
recollection in fairness to Jordan he
did say I am NOT a dietician not giving
people advice but the problem is that if
it's true in his book is the
best-selling book in the world in the
last 12 months
then he has this enormous enormous
number of people listening to him and
people that tons of that yeah and all of
a sudden moving out the Jordan beats and
beef diet
beef and so on up
that's probably not smart but anyways to
go back to the original point sleep
isn't something that you can repackage
in that way yes so it doesn't I don't
think it has the fad potential I think
that various sleep technology see and
sometimes the fact themselves aren't a
bad thing insofar as they continue to
engage people with the behaviors that
they need to carry out on a regular
basis to be healthy so I don't care if
somebody uses a new toy in order to
accomplish that if it keeps them doing
what they need to be doing and that's
great if the focus is on so if the blue
blocking glasses mean that you're
thinking about your sleep as a byproduct
then cool exactly if you're taking
melatonin in an hour before bedtime and
that's the start of your pre bed routine
and it's a signal to ingrain that habit
and get in the right mindset for sleep
something we didn't touch on earlier is
the mindset and just making sure that
you have a clear mental conscious before
sleep but that's great and it's as long
as that particular behavior isn't
counterproductive mm-hmm I'm all for
really it's a very holistic view of the
subject area and of the of the market or
industry if you want to call it as a
whole from yourself I can imagine that
for some people in other industries this
level of attention would actually be
quite threatening oh well here we go The
Charlatans of rubbing their hands
together ready to capitalize on this and
start spreading disinformation but as
you say because it's quite specialist
field the heavily research to one degree
or another although perhaps not not
entirely understood yet that there seems
to be less opportunity for this
disinformation to be to be pushed
hmm yeah I completely agree and anyway I
just hope that that particular
engagement with the importance of sleep
is something that's sustained over time
fantastic so what I want to finish on I
want to finish on two things we're gonna
go on a human OS in a moment but the the
cognitive function and and how your how
your sleep affects that are there any
final ways
you think that people can improve if
they've had a bad night's sleep what can
they do the next day to just kind of get
themselves moving a little bit okay so
I'm just gonna park that for one second
just say first if it's possible try to
Bank sleep before if you know you're
gonna go through one of those days yeah
another thing is that you should plan
menial tasks for these days you're not
going to be at your best you shouldn't
be sending important messages that have
long-term consequences and and so on
these days you don't do things that
they're gonna impair with impaired your
ability to get good sleep that night
okay so with all that said what can you
do on those days one thing is release
the temperature so slightly
uncomfortable temperatures do boost
vigilance and they're not gonna impair
your sleep at all so if for example you
can expose yourself to slightly colder
temperatures then you're gonna raise
your alertness in the short-term so that
can be things like cold showers but also
if you're in an air-conditioned room
then maybe just adjusting the settings
will help you maintain alertness during
that period of time another thing is
light exposure so I mentioned the
effects of bright lights on cognition so
you spend lots of time outdoors that's
going to be really important if you're
up during daylight naps are something
that we touched on and I think that they
can be really useful so why would you
use and that one reason would be
improving your ability to form new
memories and they improve various types
of memory formation so you have these
procedural memories which are memories
of how to carry out specific tasks how
to ride a bike how to hit a cricket ball
whatever it might be you have
declarative memories which are memories
of facts so I know that 8 plus 6 is 14
whatever it might be another purpose
would be to temporarily boost your
energy so we spoke about how that
10-minute nap seems to have the greats
of short-term effects on your energy
levels slightly longer naps will have
this sleep inertia consequence
immediately afterwards but that will
dissipate and then later they'll have
stronger alerting effects is there
is there a period of sleep inertia that
how long is that is it half an hour is
it a couple of hours it's it's probably
once you pass about 20 minutes or so as
soon as you enter into deep sleep
especially if you wake up from deep
sleep you're going to experience that
sleep inertia yeah it's the sleep cycles
they tend to last about 90 minutes on
average so let's say that you had a 90
minute sleep cycle and then you woke up
at the end of a period of REM sleep in
which you're dreaming
you'd probably actually feel okay after
there's but a half hour a nap when you
wake up from one of the deeper stage
asleep then you'd experience that sleep
inertia another function of naps is your
ability to learn new things so while
you're awake
your brain is forming all of these new
synaptic connections and during sleep
those scale down so your brain figures
out what do I need to hold on to what's
useful information for my long-term
viability and what's not
and it retains the useful information
and then it frees up new space by
pruning away the connections that it
doesn't think are important so it will
actually have it will actually have very
valuable effects if for example you're a
bit short on sleep and you're studying
hard for exams just taking that nap will
both enhance your memory consolidation
but then also free up some space for you
to learn new things to that's what also
boosts your immune function temporarily
and after sleep deprivation for example
having both nocturnal sleep and a nap
has an additive boost on immune function
and then naps will buffer against the
effects of losing sleep so if you've
lost some time so what you're saying is
it sleeps the panacea that than that but
the daily nap is the is the cure well
I'm very short on sleep then actually
just just having a brief nap however
brief it is is often going to be really
really useful I mean who'd have thought
that if you if you short on sleep that
the solution was to try and get some
sleep
yeah so I wonder what the human OS can
you can you try and explain for the
listeners what that is
yeah so we never in an age when we have
different apps for everything relates to
our health so have a meditation app you
have a Fitbit on which you track your
physical activity in your sleep and then
maybe you go to various websites for
information about about how to live a
more healthy lifestyle and what we tries
to human OS is consolidate all of that
in one place so Dan's created than the
CEO has created this loop model to
sustain health behaviors and the
fundamental premise is that we educate
people about what they need to do to be
healthy we let them track their
behaviors to see if they're carrying out
those behaviors and then we also let
them see if those behaviors are moving
in the needle in the right direction so
it's a platform that you can sign up for
and it will integrate with various
wearable devices so things like fitbit's
and M fits and so on we create online
courses about things like diet and sleep
you have a podcast and the blog to which
I regularly contribute and we have
various plans in the future also to pump
out protocols to help people navigate
certain common situations that we all
face on a regular basis so for example
I'm short on sleep today I don't a mess
of my sleep what should I do
what's everything that I can do in order
for me to be at my best in these
circumstances without having a long-term
negative effect on my health so the SOS
button for a for a couple of situations
that might happen yeah yeah exactly
and we also try to bridge the gap
between the information and the actual
practice so for example we have courses
on your cooking and there are daily
workout so it's just somewhere you can
check in each day to keep you engaged
with the behaviors which ultimately are
important for your health and to try and
make it sustainable and fun that's
awesome well I'm really excited to get
stuck into the site a signed up earlier
on I know that very kindly Eric from
human OS HQ has
set up a discount code so for anyone
who's listening who wants to check the
site out you can sign up for free for
the basic version or if you use the code
modern wisdom you can get one month for
a dollar at human OS dot me is that
correct
perfect fantastic so Greg would you be
able to tell the listeners where they
can find you online please yeah I'm just
gonna point in towards everything human
OS related so human arrest stop me you
can find human eyes stop me on Facebook
and Ginny who is another of my
colleagues there regularly puts things
up there just views and news and brief
synopsis of interesting studies they've
been published recently there's Jim know
s act human RS underscore me on Twitter
and I would say check out the podcast
and the blog so the podcast is something
that covers sleep in great depth but
also a variety of other topics
particularly focusing on various
advances in technologies that could be
various promising and countering things
like aging in the future and
technologies that consumers can use to
improve their engagement with these
important behaviors too and then also
have a look at the blog so that is
everywhere you can find you know s
online fantastic
well Greg I really appreciate your time
it's been a there's been an awful lot to
learn there and I thought I genuinely
thought coming in that I was going to
hear just a repackaged information that
I either knew anecdotally or I knew from
reading online or from Matthew Walker's
book but it seems like the subject area
is so so complex and and there's so much
for people to to understand that it I
really like what you say about people
having to engage with it as a a cared
about metric of their health a cared
about habit that they have to do as
opposed to just that thing that happens
at night and hopefully we've helped
impressed on people today just how
important it is and some of the tactics
they can do to help so and indeed amiss
tactics too so
I don't want people to feel overwhelmed
by the number of different things that
we've spoken about I would just say okay
this is your lifestyle at the moment you
think that that particular behavior is
something that you can easily try give
it a go you have to try anything else
and actually having that type of
attitude where you just see yourself as
a self experiment and you try all these
different things that you think okay but
might help me probably won't hurt me I'm
just gonna trial it for a period of time
and see how I get on is a really healthy
attitude so making sure that you can
just keep doing what you need to do in a
long time I agree well Greg thank you so
much for your time good luck with the
human always stop me development I will
be keeping a keeping my eyes peeled very
very closely as you as you release more
of your content
thanks a million Chris cheers mate
[Music]